The most pressing issue to me is Social
Responsibility.
So, we have 20 people here
that are social entrepreneurs
selected by the trust foundation that try
to combine
social responsibility and business.
So, how can we move towards
a more responsible world?
Because it can be very romantic by saying
"we have to change this, we have to change
that"
what about Climate Change? What about this?"
But at the end of the day
the person who is fighting or struggling for
a new system,
or for clean energy, or for women who are
mutilated since birth.
These are basically the real issues that nobody
discusses.
So, let's take time, and do our mission in
life because our life is our mission.
So the question is, are we doing enough, to
try transform our lives into our missions?